7 quel que je le connaisse une tour
d'ivoire madame pépin j'aime beaucoup de
respect pour elle parce que moi je suis
dans les arts de cette aquarelle et alec
d'utiliser en présence de sem chose
qu'attend la politique monsieur des fois
quand les médecins il se rend du tout
les médecins veulent être ministre
alors oui effectivement c'est rendu que
tous les médecins veulent être ministre
alors on est allé se promener
aujourd'hui à brossard ça c'était dans
le dix30
ce matin on a demandé aux gens puisque
vous êtes déchiré entre fatima houda
peut peindre votre député libéral
ex-député libéral qui est maintenant
candidate indépendante vous savez elle a
quitté le parti libéral parce que le
chef lui a montré la porte parce qu'il
n'était pas d'accord avec la ligne du
parti sur la charte de la laïcité et
gaétan barrette la prise importante du
parti et libéral en début de campagne
donc qu'il veut il veut espère devenir
ministre la santé essayez avec la cac
ils essayent maintenant avec les
libéraux un compte et donc où il ya
beaucoup d'immigration 40 % de toutes
sortes d'origine donc quand comptez deux
classes moyennes c'est la ville de
brossard vous connaissez des banlieues
plus cossus d'autres plus moyen des
poches de pauvreté également dans la
pinière donc vraiment circonscription
qui sera à suivre
c'est jamais arrivé petites notes en
votre tâche depuis 1966 ou un
indépendant a gagné au québec
donc madame fatima houda pépin est
consciente ce n'est pas facile de faire
campagne comme indépendante les ya pas
que du candidat bien sûr il y en a
quatre
le parti québécois a vient de donner son
nom on ne voit pas sur le tableau la
cactées jean king fatima houda-pepin que
tabarez paraître et joanes beaupré pour
québec solidaire le parti québécois
c'est un ancien chef de cabinet de la
ministre
véronique hivon donc qui serait et qui
sera confirmé au cours des prochains
jours mais la bataille se fait et c'est
vraiment ce qui est particulier d'un
brassard entre deux fédéraliste une
ancienne libéral 14 ans député et un
nouveau libéral
je les ai rencontrés un peu plus tôt
monsieur carignan vous remercier de me
donner l'occasion de venir vous
rencontrer aujourd'hui je suis candidate
indépendante
il sait je suis dans la même situation
dans le sens où il faut se battre pour
les citoyens madame houda pépin ski
ce qui frappe on a entendu tout à
l'heure au carrefour jeunesse c'est vous
devez expliquer aux gens d'emblée dont
je sais je suis candidat indépendant
mais vous allez voir je pourrais
peut-être faire quelque chose
donc c'est quand même un obstacle de
plus pour vous par rapport à la
verglacée à dire que c'est assez inusité
que d'avoir une députée qui sortent sur
ses convictions de son parti parce
qu'elle a été exclue de par son chef
avec lequel elle est une divergence
d'opinion sur un sujet précis je suis
sortie contre les tchadors ça n'a pas
plu à monsieur guillard sa position
qu'il a adoptée sans consultation avec
le caucus libéral fait mal au parti
libéral du québec je lui ai dit j'aurais
souhaité que l'on puisse se positionner
mieux que ça vous bouchard taylor pour
les signes religieux pour les seniors
licite pour les signes religieux
interdiction du tchador de la burqa et
du niqab alors l'épisode du tchador dans
lequel monsieur couillard s'est fourvoyé
royalement société pour moi over my dead
body sur la question de l'autorité
contraignante à savoir les juges les
procureurs les policiers et les agents
correctionnels
monsieur couillard a dit aucune
interdiction pour personne j'ai dit
qu'il y à une dérive dans cette position
là bien que je sois respectueuse de la
charte des droits
bien que je sois respectueuse du fait
que la le droit en tant que tel soit un
guide pour les positions comprend il
faut aussi regarder les autres
dimensions du problème
l'islamisme radical vous dites a des
racines au québec avant sondagière chez
nous qu'ils aient 53 % des québécois
pensent que l'intégrisme est présent au
québec
vous vous êtes d'accord avec ça parce
que quand on voyage un peu quand on
compare un peu 11 ea montréal quand même
assez paisible entend donc j'aimerais
vous entendre
mais premièrement les intégrismes qu'il
faut conjuguer au pluriel se manifeste
dans les différentes niches
savez vous combien à brassaï à deux
groupes par une manche au courant on a
fait des recherches c'est pas clair les
gens disent c'est vraiment
infinitésimale vous avez l'air à koné
des choses qu'on connaît pas ben
justement l'une des raisons pourquoi je
voulais que les gens connaissent ce
phénomène
lassé d'avoir proposé dans le projet de
loi la création d'un centre de recherche
action sur la lutte aux intégristes au
québec
oui de façon sérieuse et documentée oui
est-ce que la menace intégriste
elle est présent bien sûr maintenant il
faut dans le sens où il y à des groupes
qui sont organisés qui sont rattachés
aussi aux autres groupes qui se déploie
sur le plan international qui sont
financés vous savez dans les mosquées
les immeubles et ils sont pas élus par
la population ils arrivent formé de
l'étranger pays de l'étranger
dissimulant un discours de l'étranger
qui est très préoccupant
particulièrement pour les jeunes
madame houda-pepin l'entrée en scène de
pierre karl péladeau à faire revenir la
souveraineté à l'avant plan certains
parlent encore de en peignant d'une
élection référendaire bon alors il ya
des choses imprévues qui sont arrivés ça
vous quel effet savent ça en brosse à ce
que les fédéralistes risque pas de
revenir au parti libéral pour s'assurer
qu'ils apprennent notre référendum
mais si les libéraux de la pinière
veulent voter libéral il voterait pour
une libérale authentiquement fédéraliste
et salle s'appelle fatima houda pépin
moi je suis député je suis candidate
indépendante par la volonté des faits
des prix à je n'ai jamais quitté le
parti libéral du québec que vous
souhaitez revenir je n'ai jamais on
verra pour la chose les
je suis des choses mais fondamentalement
au moment où je vous parle j'ai
contribué pendant 20 ans au parti
libéral du québec en 1995 pendant que
gaétan barrette de voter pour la
séparation
moi j'ai fait deux sans trois cent
trente rencontres avec différents
groupes au québec à montréal a jusqu'à
sherbrooke pour défendre quoi pour
défendre la place du québec à
l'intérieur de la fédération
alors votez fatima houda pépin dans la
première c'est voter gagnant c'est voter
authentiquement pour une femme qui est
qui soutiennent pour ses convictions et
être libéral est et fédéralistes pour
moi cela fait partie de mes convictions
moi j'ai refusé d'aller avec la cac et
je n'aurais jamais joué à changer de
parti parce que je suis fondamentalement
libéral pl club douloureux
monsieur j'ai eu une discussion avec
monsieur
legault j'avais donc oui monsieur
legault m'a proposé et j'ai eu une bonne
discussion avec lui très amical et je
lui ai dit que j'étais libre entièrement
libéral ils n'ont pas libéral à moitié
donc il veut mettre la machine
oui exactement comme ma chaîne rossia
oui les pancartes
mangane et chats la machine libérale
sérieusement va écouter conclusions mais
moi je suis très confiante mais j'ai le
plus grand respect à l'égard des
citoyens du comté de la pinière je le
redis le 7 avril voter effectivement
parce que c'est une valeur sûre
parce que c'est une députée qui a été
éprouvée qui vous est servi avec loyauté
avec intégrité avec honnêteté et qui n'a
jamais dit xavier avec quelque parti que
ce soit une chance voilà vous dopez très
bonne fin de campagne
merci beaucoup merci plaisir je barrette
bonjour bonjour vous mélangez pas au
début du premier jour des tabacs la
quête non comme ça on changea médian des
français mais c'est vrai j'ai eu des
hésitations par exemple je vais prêter
encore pris en flagrant délit bord très
bien il ya 12 heures monsieur bart est
un ennemi vous étiez avec moi dans un
centre commercial à terrebonne
il m'avait dit en deux ans gouvernement
de la cac en faire en sorte que chaque
des trois mois mon médecin de famille
il n'y aura plus là vous avez baissé un
peu la barre vous êtes aperçu quoi
c'était que les gens n'en pouvait plus
des promesses lakic sont irréalistes
regardez aujourd'hui on a ri avec un
programme qui fait en sorte qu'on va
aller dans cette direction là sans
mettre un délai spécifique des rennais
mais quand on regarde ce qui est proposé
c'est pas des paroles en l'air
par exemple les super acquérir ces types
de cloud vont augmenter de plus à
hauteur de 1 à 1,5 million de visites
par et nous ont dit oui ça a des allures
cet envers l'homme et les fameuses
groupes de médecine familiale gmf qui
devait tout régler je peux vous avez non
pas vous mais essayer d'avoir un rendez
vous doit votre enfant peu fier d'avoir
qu'on n'ait pas inscrit qu'on n'est pas
un médecin de famille l'un au numéro
faut laisser un message penser plus ça
marche tout comme on avait dit que ça
marche
vous avez raison et vous avez tout à
fait raison moi je vais dans les
souliers des gens ayant raison vous
pensez vraiment vous que les québécois
qui vous écoutent à brossard se disent
avec lui oui ce sera vraiment différent
par rapport à un plastique tout le monde
veut que ça marche en principe on dirait
que c'est la chanson de dalida paroles
paroles points justement j'ai pas encore
vu personnellement
l'occasion de faire partie d'une équipe
qui avait le pouvoir pour passer la
parole aux actes là je suis convaincu
que je vais pouvoir la faire vous savez
j'ai pas changé en deux heures
ben oui vous avez changé vous avez
changé de parti je dois changer
personnellement vous êtes genre d'homme
tout cas vente position vous faites un
calcul est ce que ça peut être rentable
si je serai pas là pourriez vous voulez
agir l'épaule heures est prêt dans
l'opposition ouais c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de vous dire c'est un pari
peut-être plus risqué que je croyais
non mais
pas du tout au contraire les décisions
qui se prennent pour faire en sorte que
quelque chose se passe en santé sa peine
au vert et si vous êtes dans
l'opposition est ce que vous restez
quatre ans avec plaisir parce que c'est
un conte et j'ai hâte de travailler
d'augmenter la réponse est oui
la réponse est oui et c'est un oui ferme
elles connaissent ils sont humains
qu'est ce que les gens disent à mon côté
je suis obligé par de l'alphabet la
dernière fois j'étais dans un autre
convoi que je vous retrouve ici
ouais exactement vous avez appris vous
avez regardé j'ai fait aux j'ai
rencontré des jeunes époux ici j'avais
pas ici et avait par contre c'est un
compte et qui est facile à embrasser
c'est un conte et j'attendrai une
personne dans une surface assez dense là
c'est une élection où on parle beaucoup
de l'effet monde je n'assure pas un peu
ben je pensais pas que le parti
québécois allaient aller aussi à
l'aigreur dans ce débat là c'est un
choix qui ont fait le buzz qui doit
décider de polariser la société ça
marche alors servette nous contre eux
parce qu est le seul parti qui peut les
arrêter
c'est une honte votre ancien parti s'il
est impossible ne peut pas le faire zink
outillage n'avait pas pas sympa et en
état des voies la santé et ses cadres
économiques et il faut les claviers
basse est fini pour moi personnellement
mais je dis si vous croyez que c'est
terminé
il est clair il ya pas la plus élevée
pour le parti et pour le québec
il est clair qu'elle la division du vote
à savoir libéral parce que la cac cède à
saveur libéral vlp ouvrage à l'effet moi
j'ai divisé le vote
j'ai été instrumental dans la mise en
place d'un mouvement intégriste
minoritaires j'ai considéré pour moi que
c'était une erreur que j'ai décidé
d'abord à faire deux fois sajjad jour
pour votre égo de perdre pour vous suit
travers ce qui n'était pas connue
n'était pas au candidat pinon
quand je regarde l'élection de 20 ans
quand je me suis présenté y avait une
très très grande distance que j'ai
résulte beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup mais
bien les quand même mais j'ai pas cet
angle là moi c'est non ne vous étonnez
jamais alors oui j'aime bien les
batailles légendaires des garniers vers
démocratie la démocratie c'est le peuple
qui parle un peu comment chercher de
plus pour limite c'est pourquoi vous
avez gants il sait pas quand vous gagnez
un argumentaire le corps va avec vous
mes mains ou encore les dossiers à 66
noda fans gays tabarez dernière question
rapidement le taf il 95 c'est pas clair
faisait voter oui
ce qui est clair c'est que j'ai dit à
madrid lorsqu'il me recruter mais je ne
suis pas allé au pq si j'étais eux
partie des choix d'alain je les ai vus
que comme soit très sincèrement c'est la
réalité que je venais d'une famille
souvent y est vous l'avez laissé penser
que je lui ai dit que je vais voter non
qui dit je sais que c'est pas ce qu'il
dit mais il ya bien des choses qu'elle
placerait le croit dit qu'ils sont
pauvres mais vous auriez eu droit de
voter oui je sais je lui dois de voter
oui le volet suivant et vos cheveux ou
0,80 g pas voter parce que j'étais à
l'étranger de me poser la question je
veux demander ce que la prochaine pour
jose interview
j'aurais pas candidat pour le parti
québécois avait surgi je vais rencontrer
monsieur dray attendait de moi je
magasine arié ces gens d'affaires par
rapport aux quais toc toc toc la barre
est on voudrait vous rencontrer seriez
vous intéressés à suivre et qui voulez
vous donner le chum la direction dans ce
set ça c'est clair il aurait été bon de
faire campagne on verra d'ailleurs aussi
alors j'ai bien confiance je suis très
content d'être ici qu on saluera contre
eux aussi